o Olá eu sou a Patrícia tem que eu estou
aqui no Dex da faabb super legal para
tratar com vocês de matemática que é
inovação e regulamentação é como estamos
vivendo essa transformação digital e
intensa Então vou compartilhar que com
vocês não é justamente uma visão assim
de como que nós estamos vivenciando essa
realidade né o nós e o futuro é isso que
a gente pode perceber com tudo isso que
nós estamos passando né O que que tá
acontecendo quando a gente fala de
inovação e regulamentação o que que já é
a primeira coisa que vem à cabeça né as
ondas do chumbo e ter né gente lembra aí
da destruição criativa e nós vivemos aí
praticamente até 2020 a quinta onda do
Sul
Oi E Agora Nós entramos na sexta ontem
2021 então assim nós vimos todo fenômeno
das redes digitais das novas mídias ali
dos anos 90 até 2020 foram 30 anos
vivenciando né esse salto e o que que é
essa sexta onda do super essa onda do
Smart tudo ficando mais inteligente vem
a inteligência artificial a internet das
coisas o Big deita e não é só
Inteligência Artificial pensando Mach
Lane tradicional do jeito que a gente já
ouviu falar que começou lá nos anos 50
60 e depois o pessoal Desistiu depois o
pessoal voltou acreditar na Inteligência
Artificial agora é aquele conceito novo
de playboy ai né Ou seja que a gente
consegue explicar a tomada de decisão da
máquina porque hoje em dia ainda
acontece de a gente não entender como
que o algoritmo chegou naquela decisão
é uma série de desdobramentos né gente
vai falar aqui justamente disso né como
que vamos desenhar um frame work aí para
Essa sociedade da sexta onda que aqueles
que dizem que vamos alcançar a
singularidade até 2045 ser a gente você
acha Você acredita na singularidade Será
que o singularity vai chegar em 2045
Quem Viver Verá bem de acordo com ao mês
com dado interessante né a gente tem que
cair em vez de mais trazer mais mulheres
supermercado de Inteligência Artificial
e é um mercado que espera gerar 4
trilhões de dólares aí em 2022 tem
crescido muito registro de patente de
algoritmos principalmente no iOS Pit ou
nos Estados Unidos e realmente tem
trazido aí muitas oportunidades Mas será
que a gente tem
a lamentar a inteligência artificial o
que que você acha né A partir do momento
que a gente tem Inovação de um lado será
que temos que estabelecer regras limites
né definir quem responde né
responsabilidade A partir dessa situação
que vamos viver cada vez mais cercados
por robôs por Inteligência Artificial
por decisão mais autônoma as notícias
mostram que a gente já está com essa
realidade assim ao nosso retor você já
teve a chance de andar num carro
autônomo existe o cm autônomo não é
aquele que você pode estar conduzindo E
aí de vez em quando o carro toma um
controle é a muitos países que isso tem
sido estabelecido até em certos tipos de
Frota como de caminhões né os carros ou
troque né o caminhão autônomo é muito
interessante ainda mais em longas
distâncias o períodos noturnos com toda
a certeza
a discutir que você diminui acidentes
mais ainda existe aqueles lado de você
tem que programar no carro uma série de
cenários ali dentro do algoritmo e a
quem fala que você tem aquela Black Box
que a caixa-preta né Depois que você
todas as decisões e tudo que fica
registrado é esse carro mais inteligente
ele sabe tudo que aconteceu dentro do
veículo é e pode contar pode ser chamado
para depor porque na era digital a
testemunha é a máquina é E aí hoje
quando acontece um incidente envolvendo
um carro mais autônomo amor que esse
piloto autônomo estava dirigindo que é o
robô fica discussão quem responde Ainda
mais se tiver um acidente fatal como que
fica a responsabilidade Então essa é uma
questão que o direito tá discutindo que
a sociedade está discutindo Será que vai
ser uma responsabilidade já do
fabricante
é mas nós sabemos que você tem uma
limitação do que vem do setup de fábrica
será que você tem uma responsabilidade
depois do dono da Inteligência
Artificial do proprietário existe um
princípio do direito que a coisa parece
para o dono quando uma coisa Nossa faz
uma coisa errada responde o dono da
coisa por exemplo se você hoje tem um
assistente conversacional né você tem
ali a Siri Alexa você vai ensinando ela
você fala com ela ela vai aprender
inclusive com você então tem uma coisa
que vem ali programada pelo fabricante
Mas tem uma parte que eu aprendizado de
máquina que nós por convivência um ótimo
Elaine ali com o seu dono com os demais
usuários um também a discussão se
deveria definir uma responsabilidade do
eu eletrônico da própria Inteligência
Artificial dizer o robô errou o robô
responde né Será que já chegou ao ponto
dizer então no seguro Tem que cobrir
a máquina Ela será que ele vai aprender
máquina nessa máquina fazer uma coisa
assim criminosa que estava fora de
controle aí a gente lembra né gente
aquelas leis da robótica do asimov quem
é que não lembra A gente levanta do
filme do Robocop entre outros já estamos
vivendo essa realidade aqui e a uma
pesquisa feita nos Estados Unidos muito
interessante feita pela tripla Way
American como Bill association' de que
ainda esse consumidor final esse usuário
é tem um pouco de receio da condução
totalmente autônoma ou seja o ser humano
se sente um pouco mais tranquilo Se ele
perceber que existe ainda uma supervisão
humana e isso tá sendo extraído dessas
pesquisas para definir a gente vai ter
que ter uma lei uma regulamentação que
diga que sempre vai ter que ter humano
que manda na máquina e que a máquina não
vai poder ter essa autonomia completa e
voltamos lá na sim
e eu tava falando aqui com vocês e a
gente tem visto até das notícias sem as
questões éticas né vários e várias
situações em que nós já tivemos questões
assim ofensas de assédio né tanto o
alguém falando com a máquina ofender a
ela como a própria a a máquina Ou seja a
inteligência artificial na linguagem né
aprender palavreados que podem acabar
tendo um resultado que pode ser
preconceituoso discriminatório
considerado ofensivo né então assim é
interessante que a na parte de Mach Lane
Você tem todo um aprendizado com grande
volume de bases de dados mas essas bases
de dados às vezes refletem a história
reflete no passado e nós hoje temos
programas de diversidade de combate
assédio que querem prever uma
sustentabilidade uma governança Para o
Futuro
É mas não queremos repetir o passado a
gente aprende com passado que é melhorar
Para o Futuro Então como que a gente
consegue apresentar para esse algoritmo
que está aprendendo no nível da
inteligência para que ele consiga por
exemplo discernir verdade de mentira
para que ele conseguir entender o que é
malícia para que ele consiga aprender
com que ele vai analisar dessas bases de
dados mas aplicar melhores práticas para
o futuro nós não queremos usar um
palavreado que no passado pode ter sido
considerado razoável mas que para os
dias de hoje e para o futuro já não é
considerado aceitável já é ofensivo já é
preconceituoso e assim por diante como
responder de forma adequada a todas
essas situações né Pra que muitas coisas
vão se passar pelo lado educativo
Educacional E aí vem uma profissão muito
nova que tá rolando que essa treinador
de robô né você tá
eu vou para ele poder ficar espertinho
com tudo isso e demora o botão Fica
espertinho rápido Tem havido todo um
levantamento então em cima dessas
questões a ONU publicou um estudo né
para gente poder ficar o bonitinho os
racistas e isso foi avaliado inclusive
nas questões de vídeo vigilância é as
câmeras de reconhecimento facial e com o
uso de videovigilância seja como a gente
pode reduzir o Bias o viesse nesse uso
aí dividir o vigilância de câmeras com
reconhecimento facial e que podem até
ter falso-positivo e assim por diante é
também se identificou quem muitos
projetos se a equipe que desenvolve
aquele algoritmo todos os
desenvolvedores todo mundo que tá no
projeto é por exemplo todos da pele
branca todos de um perfil de idade todos
de um perfil Cultural de um mesmo perfil
religioso você pode tender
é um viés então a multidisciplinaridade
e trabalhar essa essa possibilidade de
ter um grupo de trabalho mas é misturado
né com mais diversidade já contribui
para o resultado final do algoritmo
também reduziu viés não é interessante é
um lá na prancheta lá na programação
você já tem que trabalhar com a
diversidade e também a base de dados tem
que ter muito cuidado é mas você precisa
de um algoritmo para ajudar a reduzir o
viés de outro algoritmo E aí também tem
que se falado das questões de
Transparência hoje você já tem
algoritmos para determinar prioridades
na internação da UTI e pensando que
estamos vivendo toda a pandemia de
covid-19 quer dizer aquele que se sinta
preterido vai querer saber e aí Mas
quais foram os fatores os pesos o que
e essa tomada de decisão Então você vai
precisar de um comitê ético que defina
transparência e isso as novas
regulamentações já estão trazendo quando
a gente olha a legislação de proteção de
dados pessoais que a lei 3709 chamada LG
perder no Brasil é de 2018 entrou em
vigor em setembro de 2020 ela tem o
artigo 6º que já fala de transparência e
não-discriminação e ela tem o seu artigo
20 da fala sobre revisão de decisão
automatizada que você pode solicitar
como titular que seja apresentado o
detalhamento de como que foi feita a
decisão algorítmica né e passo jeito
inclusive aquele controlador de dados
que tem o algoritmo a passar por uma
Auditoria da autoridade Nacional de
Proteção de dados para verificar se
houve discriminação do algoritmo não é
muito legal muito interessante Então E
aí nós já temos
a tentações nos Estados Unidos que
cresceu muito de 2015 para cá na Europa
e o próprio Brasil tá andando com
regulamentação nós temos um brasileiro
ajudando a Unesco para pensar uma lei
global de Inteligência Artificial não é
aquela visão de pensarmos em tratado
internacional é uma visão ética da
Inteligência Artificial ou para quem
puder acesse ó lhe acompanhe Ainda mais
se você pensar em projetos desse tipo
essa primeira versão para um tratado
internacional de ética na Inteligência
Artificial está pensando abordando
aprendizado de máquina raciocínio de
máquina sistemas ciberfísicos internet
das coisas sistemas robóticos robótica
social interface homem-computador Nossa
gente que legal né olha só que temática
interessante Além disso exige que cumpra
com valores de respeito proteção e
promoção da
Oi mana direitos humanos e liberdades
fundamentais Tem que atender diversidade
inclusão e pensar na harmonia e paz ou
seja não pode promover a guerra tem que
separar ajudar com a paz e deve
considerar princípios como da
proporcionalidade e não causa danos
segurança e proteção Justice
não-discriminação sustentabilidade
privacidade supervisão e determinação
humana Olha aí né o Tratado
internacional já estão colocando de que
tem que ter supervisão humana e aí
transparência e explicabilidade a
palavrinha explicabilidade vem do
explainable E ai eu conseguir explicar a
tomada de decisão da máquina para fechar
concluir fica no nosso radar os quatro
projetos de lei brasileiros estão
catando da Inteligência Artificial então
a gente acelera na inovação mas também
tá mandando na regulamentação ou seja
a gente pode usar das novas tecnologias
mas tem que ser com regras claras com
transparência com segurança e
respeitando os direitos humanos vou
ficando por aqui com vocês e espero que
você tenha gostado dessa tendência para
o futuro aqui no card ex da Fabi muito
obrigada só Patricia Peck sou
especialista em direito digital em
inovação saiba segurança e proteção de
dados até mais é